the trailer for The 2024 edition of
Roadhouse has finally dropped and it
looks like a crowd bler so why is it
only going to Amazon's streaming
platform and not theaters in 1989
Patrick sesy stepped into the shoes of
James Dalton a bouncer who protects a
little town from the ferious capitalist
in Roadhouse the film quickly found an
audience and has achieved cult-like
status pain on hurt in 2021 Edge of
Tomorrow director Doug Lyman signed on
to remake the film with the Contemporary
take and that film has finally come to
fruition in the trailer Jakob gyllen
Hall's Elwood Dalton is a down on his Lu
ex UFC fighter whose Glory Days are
behind him he's given the opportunity to
be a bouncer at a Florida Keys Roadhouse
and of course a simple gig turns chaotic
soon a businessman attempts to transform
the watering hole into a resort leading
to former UFC champion Conor McGregor's
character going toe-to-toe with Dalton
from Lush visuals to hard-hitting action
sequence quences Roadhouse looks like an
absolute knockout for Lyman and gyllen
Hall the day before the trailer for
Roadhouse debuted Lyman a proven
hitmaker in Hollywood highlighted his
grievances with Amazon Studios for not
giving the film a theatrical release so
why isn't Prime vide sending the film to
Cinemas like Ben Affleck air in a guest
column for deadline the director argued
that the decision was likely due to an
algorithm that cares more about quote
selling toasters than supporting movie
theaters or creative artists in March
the film will Premiere at the South by
Southwest Film Festival but Lyman wrote
that he won't attend the event he added
the facts I signed up to make a
theatrical motion picture for MGM Amazon
bought MGM Amazon said make a great film
and we'll see what happens I made a
great film Lyman also wrote that exec's
widely praised Roadhouse and labeled it
as a Smash Hit highlighting the film's
highly positive test scores but even
with the film's a claim Amazon isn't
choosing to bank on the film's financial
viability with a theatrical rollout nor
allow him to sell to another Studio that
would financially support and market a
theatrical release lion wrote If we
don't put Temple movies in movie
theaters there won't be movie theaters
in the future Amazon asked me in the
film Community to trust them and their
public statements about supporting
Cinemas and then they turned around and
are using Roadhouse to sell Plumbing
fixtures the director also contended
that a straight to streaming release
deprives jillen Hall Of Glory once award
season comes around too a bummer
considering Lyman called this a career
defining role for the star no one ever
wins a fight one can't help but feel
sympathetic for Lyman and gyen Hall in
this scenario especially after Amazon
Studios promised that they'd put a
billion dollars into theatrical Motion
Pictures after buying MGM Studios Lyman
signed up to make a theatrical picture
and now he feels that Amazon shafted him
the trailer for the Remake is genuinely
impressive and a lineman has aous Heats
to back up the praise the FM received
from exx if Roadhouse was given a
theatrical release it's honestly not
hard to imagine it making a pretty penny
at the box office like another MGM
release The Beekeeper which is on track
to gross more than $85 million by the
end of its theatrical run to its further
credit Roadhouse has significant ties to
the globally popular UFC the film was sh
at the UFC event and features several
iconic Fighters including McGregor over
1.5 billion UFC fans have engaged with
post about the release of Roadhouse on
social media too if marketed well to UFC
and action movie fans Roadhouse could
have made a killing at the box office
alas the 2024 take on Roadhouse will
stream on Prime video starting March
21st unless that
[Music]
changes